2024 are you getting ready
and I am too
after a week of midterm elections
Fallout many Republicans blame the
former president in part for the lack of
a red wave I think that American people
voted for sanity and speculation over
whether this speech would even happen
members of the former president's Inner
Circle have advised Trump to put off the
announcement Donald Trump has finally
made his intentions clear in order to
make America great and glorious again I
am tonight announcing my candidacy for
president of the United States
but if Donald Trump wins the nomination
in 2024 he has a very good shot at
becoming president
the speech itself was a boiled over
version of the campaign speeches that
he's been giving all throughout this
year he depicted basically the country
as in precipitous decline ever since he
left office and again his pitch was that
he alone could fix it but interestingly
he largely refrained from reiterating uh
his point which he's really had a tough
time letting go of that he thinks the
last election was stolen and corrupt he
ad-libbed a line about how China might
have stolen the election from him in
2020 which I think was relatively new
and and certainly unscripted China
played a very active role
in the 2020 election just saying just
say
sure that didn't happen but other than
that he largely steered clear of those
issues which have consumed him for the
last two years but I think the midterm
election results shook the Republican
party's faith in trumpism he tried to
spend what was almost unanimously
considered a very poor result despite
the outcome in the Senate we cannot lose
hope we have taken over Congress Nancy
Pelosi has been fired
said that he deserved the credit for
Nancy Pelosi no longer being the speaker
of the house
that is probably going to be true but
they didn't manage to in fact flip the
Senate as they had hoped and they also
lost a few governorships including four
uh devoted acolytes of his like Kerry
Lake in Arizona and Doug Montreal in
Pennsylvania but you know he was
undeterred by that reality and and still
claimed that it was a success there are
clearly other Republicans who are
thinking about entering the presidential
Fray You know at the end of the day I
would just uh tell people to go check
out the scoreboard from last Tuesday
night Raw DeSantis the Florida governor
who by contrast had a very excellent
night uh in the midterms where he won by
20 points
um looks to be ascendant in some polls
among Republicans they now say that they
prefer Ron DeSantis by a margin of about
seven points before Ron DeSantis had
been behind by quite a lot Ron DeSantis
shares Donald Trump's pugilism he has
the same enemies and that pressure might
have been why Trump went ahead and
declared his candidacy for the
presidency despite the fact that he had
just had a disappointing result in the
week before I think part of the motive
for Donald Trump declaring his candidacy
early as well is the raft of legal
challenges that he's facing at the
moment he is under investigation by
local prosecutors in Georgia over his
possible solicit nation of election
fraud he's under investigation by the
Attorney General of New York and the
January 6 committee has also been
investigating him for longer than a year
now him being an active
a candidate for the presidency obviously
complicates what was already an
extraordinarily complicated legal
situation and I think that makes it
harder to imagine that something like a
successful conviction would happen
anytime between now and the 2024
election
I think that if Donald Trump wins the
nomination in 2024 he has a very good
shot at becoming president
Americans even if they're tired of
Donald Trump are still incredibly
polarized and still have very strong
partisan allegiances that are quite hard
to break
um so the idea that some Democrats have
been espousing uh in the last week that
they would relish the opportunity to
take on Donald Trump again might
ring a lot like the feeling that many
had in 2016 when they thought that he'd
be an easy opponent and I think that
there's a risk that Democrats might yet
again be underestimating his chances
thank you for watching to read more of
our U.S politics coverage please click
the link and also please don't forget to
subscribe